meps have narrowed the field to three in
this year's sakuraf prize for freedom of
thought
all with very different backgrounds and
profiles we have a
very good selection of people who all
stand up for
human rights for themselves but also for
others no easy task to choose between a
pakistani teenager who was shot in the
head by the taliban
three belarussian dissidents jailed
after disputing the outcome of the
presidential election in 2010
and one of the biggest whistleblowers
the world has ever seen
edward snowden we have a very broad
range you see
a courageous woman from pakistan malala
who stood up for her rights and the
rights of other girls for the right to
education
we have mr bialatsky and colleagues from
belarus
who fight an authoritarian regime and we
have
edward snowden from the united states
who stands up for the right of
information
whoever wins they'll be following in
illustrious footsteps
miami's now freed democracy activist
aung sang-soo chi
in 1990 nelson mandela two years before
five men and women representing the arab
spring in 2011.
the winner will be announced on october
the 10th with the prize awarded in
november in strasbourg